okay few things my thing yeah wear your
pants oh yeah I gotta get changed
welcome to the Oreo taste test the Oreo
or death challenge or your dunk the
Dunkin doze the Dunkin cookies the milk
and cookies challenge I mean kinda
I like this need to be your brand you
need to sell merch that is just sweat
pants shirts alright um sees a look so
today we are going to be blindfolded ly
trying Oreos but as with most of the
things that I do it's going to be a lot
more high stakes than it has in the past
if other people have done this we've got
a bucket of ice here chica we've got
five gallons of milk one of them is
fat-free which I don't believe in whole
that I do love three one percent so in a
total isn't whole milk just three
percent three point five three point
four point two five maybe listen I hold
even with fat-free milk because that's
what I drink we don't back free milk is
so gross this is delicious milk is gross
no you water gas is the thing that gives
things listen listen I like to drink
liquid not fat
what are you talking milk milk is to be
fab you know ya know the point of milk
is calcium no fat free milk juice
replaces the fat with sugar that's the
only thing that gives it flavor what do
you mean you like to drink liquid do you
not think that whole milk is some it is
a liquid but it's a fatty liquid its
thick liquids hold on
you own this okay alright this is whole
milk whole milk okay
it is it is thick okay it is thick this
is a liquid this is a liquid that is
thick there almost no that's just water
down this you can see it is delicious
that makes me choke that looks like
semen that looks like glue I'd rather
beat the blue with and semen milk out
here baby
nothing is that you're all adults
drinking milk tired look look if our
ancestors heard us all complaining about
milk while they're starving in Siberia I
don't think they would be very happy
about it so why don't we just be
grateful that we have milk and let me do
the math to add up what percentage of
milk this is once it's in this book okay
do you have total of eight point five
divided by five that's four point two
five percent milk what's the mean we're
looking for the mean three point two
five to zero
I don't remember what mean is there's
the average you like there needs to be
just one zero two threes a three three
three ones
1:03 one's a 2 and a 3 point two five
the outliers are three point two five
and zero it's so the mean has to be
between one and two
what are we trying to figure out
weighted there 1:03 ones a two and a
three point five so it's a in half total
but that's not the point yet okay one no
five over no three point three point two
five over five that's one you have 31
I'm gonna say it's one point five no we
have to get this right you distribute it
you've where's I need Excel you can do
this in Excel in two seconds maybe I
have Excel on the phone what is the
spreadsheet say crunch the numbers
actually don't know how to do that I
don't know either I was this open if you
put it in 1.41 six I see it 1.5 eyes
closed so you were not correct okay so
we need to get work we're looking for a
total we didn't compensate for the water
from the ice we don't have the volume on
why are we doing this man poor baby mine
see how the fat makes this look so much
worse no no it is so bad no thanks we
milk tastes great days off no it tastes
so watered down and diluted no nothing's
wrong with me I don't like fat
everything's right no that's my issue
you're the reason that humanity is so
overweight because you're well oh you're
part of the generation that said fat was
evil and sugar I'm not a part of the
burden just because I have a flavor
preference of that free milk over home
you need to forget about your favor for
the good not everywhere the texture and
the black that fat globs all up in my
throat I don't care all right
actually we were totally wrong because
we can't fit all okay we've got all
right this is a welcome to the Oreo or
death challenge even here is going to
taste test a bunch of Oreos and then
we're all gonna test us a bunch for you
why is it okay you can hear it much shut
okay see or your death challenge he's
gonna taste test a bunch of Oreos if he
gets it right he wins nothing if he gets
it wrong he gets dunked with ice milk
okay I would like to say that this isn't
very fair for me cuz I just had my
wisdom teeth pulled so I can't eat solid
foods yet you can still even so it's so
much harder I'm gonna tell you what the
options are because we can see it so we
don't want to have an unfair advantage
once we go because we you won't know the
options right we've got lemon we've got
chocolate we've got double stuff
double stop we've got mega stuff mint
okay hold on can I just say that the mm
the mega stuff isn't this about flavor
no you know to be able to tell the
difference okay
birthday cake birthday a good question
of what that tastes like because I don't
even know
we've got non Oreo brand Orioles know I
have to be able to tell if they're not
worried oh yeah I think vanilla or an
elephant we got white Wario's okay I
don't know if there's a flavor
difference between there but you have to
tell I don't like it so there's no basic
Oreos no normal it is also it is pretty
chilly outside today
the question I have am I allowed to ask
questions were the off-brand Oreos
normal or were they double stuffed the
off-brand was double stuff this is this
is double stuff regular double stuff oh
oh did you regular double stuff what do
you mean right is it a normal I had to
change my answer no just clarify what
you meant
yeah because the off-brand is double
filled it is Oreo it was a mess I hate
it I hate the bird box challenge mr.
stress do you want to trade out each
time then you have to keep track of
who's done one yeah I got ready through
all of them for everybody that be like a
two-hour long video all right we'll try
it out I'll try it out oh thanks you got
balls and you see no I've got my eyes
closed I don't even know why we do a
blindfold I just closed my eyes because
I is the honor system because I'm not a
spineless dick hole like you Tyler
specifically I'm sorry I called you a
spy
thank you I appreciate your apology but
I don't accept it because he still told
me well I mean I still meant it right
are you ready I'm ready I'm not getting
a lot of smell yeah well your way let's
not get ahead of ourselves here hang on
a second
this is the off-brand double-stuff is
that your final answer yes no what is it
it was mega stuf we tricked you we
didn't think that you would guess what
you just gave me haha I'm sorry it is
painful quite cold oh it's not that cold
yeah then again I haven't had anything
beside just thin in a long time thin is
the best oh it was wet before no
different now yeah but it's milky now I
don't care you spineless dick hole hey
you apologize
I'd already did so I can say this but no
you can yell the jobs each double insult
Gemma I don't even have to taste this
off-brand double so confident I don't
even have to taste double stuff no no
incorrect does that another don't know
different aftertaste yeah maybe you
should have taken your job this is
birthday cake where's your bull oh can
we get a different no it's really wet
that's how it is oh it's so hot it
happens
this is the off-brand Oreo
yeah god damn it's just it's just a very
different texture it's no longer that's
why I okay I'm not gonna get any wrong
after this okay it's definitely a thin
but hang on I'm smelling how do you
smell things not up my nose
so regular Orioles then thank you thank
you very much I am confident that this
is a cookie double stuffed Oreo say for
now dammit
we're doing good boys no any Content
Evans got some tricks up his sleeves
haven't I've been so good to you don't
betray me like this you can't modify the
cookie right no I don't think so
right you can't modify the cookie right
excuse me yes what's up you can't modify
the cookie I feel like you've modified
this I didn't modify it feels far too
thick I did not modify it
I think you've modified this cookie fan
yeah well if I did you'd have to
identify it
yeah they're ended hmm this cookies been
tampered alright
one side is definitely the lemon hmm I
can feel the separation you ready for
this boys you all right thing that it's
a lemon Oreo mixed with I could feel the
separation like with these degrees and I
was like this one is far too big Wow
really impressive impressive I'm
honestly impressed by that
well done the game is now on because I
think anything's on the table as far as
mixes and match and it have to be exact
how many are you allowed to mix it once
it's good too for this round two okay
come on give me so hard
you can't spit it things
[Laughter]
yeah y'all have to give us an answer
border your thoughts feel like it would
be this field spin
I feel spin give us an answer
shut up thing up okay this is store
brand and this is are we sticking to the
limit of only two keys you've got to
feel like this is gonna be a cream
separation you know nothin man I have an
inkling feeling that it would be a cream
separation with different cookie
so it's a lemon Oreo combined with the
thin vanilla damn we're gonna have to
get tough for boys it's my turn
I'll get to-- ah we should go easy we're
gonna dunk a lot cuz we've haven't been
dunking enough oh yeah
oh my god I'm so
[Music]
so this is the store-bought top
hmm interest
boys don't do anything you're making
showcase it's tricky because this is
definitely two different things I think
hard after reviewing the cookie I feel
as though there may have not been
another sliced icing I feel like there's
some trickery going on cuz you're like
oh we're gonna make it harder what if
you didn't what if you just gave me a
[ __ ] normal one is that your call no
I mean what are you what are you
deciding oh this isn't time even you got
to make it okay okay okay I think I
think I think it's just a double stuff
that wasn't enough of a dumb it was
double stuff outsides with the cream
from a store-bought that's like an old
slang term for a guy who has eyes for
boobs no I don't think very cold it's
cool how you feeling mark yeah I mean my
eyes are cold but I feel good I'm Way
smarter than these guys
so anything that they come up with will
just be child play for me
I don't like the giggling feel like
that's just disrespectful
[Laughter]
why did milk drip on my leg did you put
something in between - is this three
hang on okay there's some birthday cake
in here
hey whoa hey whoa hey whoa I'm over here
you've got some milk dripping down your
nose all right this is confusing okay
this is my guess I'm gonna I'm gonna
commit because I'm a man of action
I don't like it you're getting ready
with that because I'm about to nail this
to the wall mega stuf birthday cake
icing in the middle mint cake mint
the last one is chocolate oh my god this
is you are right the giggling is the
worst thing oh you know what it could be
just all bunch of regular stuff
how many boxes are you holding up
already
oh my god oh my god how many are in here
can I at least ask that no no I have so
many creams to go through so
store-bought cookies too mega stuf
creams in a store-bought cream and I got
the creams right that you I was amazed
by that yeah all right so this has been
the Oreo or death challenge or whatever
I call it at the end of it thank you
everybody so much why we don't need to
lean down I'm cold
there's beneath an entire check them out
in the description all links down there
crank game plays Apocalypto our score 12
I have a new clothing line the cranky
collection it's very nice yeah yeah so
check it out crank gameplays merch calm
if you got other ideas for stupid things
that we can do write them in the
comments below and we might do them in
the future thanks everybody so much and
as always we'll see you in the next one